adesso che il vostro apparato digerente
quando sangue a sé per digerire con calo
di ossigeno al vostro cervello parlo io
quindi o o almeno un alibi vi parlo di
biodiversità attraverso qualcosa di un
po più curioso ultimamente per fortuna e
alla buon ora stiamo sempre più sentendo
parlare di biodiversità
non molti magari di voi sanno che siamo
nel bel mezzo del decennio a essa
dedicato e questo è un po aiuta però è
un trend che possiamo registrare come
positivo ma cos'è di fatto la
biodiversità bene se cercate su internet
un altre fonti trovate definizioni che
pur se formalmente molto perfette sono
un po fredde non rendono perfettamente
giustizia al all'argomento quindi
servono degli esempi possiamo in tal
senso andare per esempio in una delle
ultime oasi di biodiversità giro per il
pianeta come per esempio la foresta
amazzonica possiamo parlare delle
infinite forme e colori che ci regalano
le orchidee
oppure ancora a citare le circa 400 mila
specie di coleotteri che rendono quello
del dei coleotteri appunto l'ordine più
vasto fra tutte le forme viventi piante
incluse ma forse giova rimanere nel
nostro paese che come già stato
ricordato è il più ricco a livello
europeo di biodiversità e parlare di
qualcosa che c'è molto comune anche
perché in questo periodo la stagionalità
cielo ce lo offre sulle nostre tavole e
parlare appunto dei cavoli tutti
conosciamo i cavoli abbiamo il
cavolfiore broccolo fra i più buoni di
tutti
vorrei citare il cavolo nero toscano mi
aspetterei un applauso particolare
abbiamo il capolino di bruxelles via via
fino a magari cavoli come il cinese e il
broccolo cinesi meno conosciuti dalle
nostre parti
perché parlare di cavoli in relazione
alla biodiversità
ebbene tutte le piante che abbiamo visto
non appartengono solo alla famiglia
delle brassicacee non appartengono tutte
al genere bro genere brassica scusate ma
sono tutte manifestazioni di un'unica
specie la brassica oleracea be nice
questa umile e se volete anonima
piantina che troviamo comunemente nei
nostri prati ha dato il via a questo
straordinario ventaglio di forme
caratteristiche e colori che sono le
varietà appunto della stessa pianta è
come se nel corso dei secoli forse anche
dei millenni i nostri antenati avessero
avuto la possibilità di plasmare una
creta particolarmente creativi vice
smaniosa di dare libero sfogo alla sua
creatività
quindi riassumendo prendete una forma di
vita anche una piantina anonima come se
ne trovano a centinaia
mettetela in un pianeta a caso che possa
ospitare darle vita e
coltivatela coccolate la selezionate dal
otterrete quella biodiversità che
abbiamo visto di visto poc'anzi
quali sono i vantaggi che cv che ci
offre questa questa biodiversità
purtroppo non ho tutta la giornata a
disposizione per elencarli tutti quindi
ci limitiamo a quelle più ovvi e più
scontati ma non meno importanti fino a
qualche stimolo particolare che che vi
mostrerò per esempio un cucina con tutte
queste varietà che che ci offre una sola
pianta possiamo scatenarci due esempi su
tutti dal cavolo cappuccio otteniamo i
crauti e dal cavolo nero otteniamo la
ribollita qui mi aspetterei tipo
un'ovazione
scherzi a parte
ancora più importante è la valenza che
riguarda la nostra la nostra salute
tutte le brassicacee ma in particolare
il broccolo hanno proprietà
straordinarie e vengono studiate in
tutto in tutto il pianeta perché sono in
grado di prevenire alcune forme tumorali
la cosa forse meno all'apparenza
importante che però vi vorrei descrivere
velocemente è la bellezza e la
creatività che si nasconde dietro a
questa pianta la faccio anche vedere e
ditemi se non la trovate straordinaria
perché perché straordinaria innanzitutto
attraverso questa pianta la natura ha
deciso di svelare un paio dei suoi
trucchetti migliori
innanzitutto il broccolo romanesco è il
miglior esempio al mondo per spiegare la
geometria frattale come come vedete
nell'animazione infatti se voi prendete
il cavolo in ogni suo elemento più
piccolo ripete la forma totale questo
possiamo arrivare a guardarlo anche al
microscopio e troverete magari
la forma della molecola a forma conica
ma c'è di più
se andiamo a contare le spirali con le
quali il broccolo si accresce nello
spazio troveremo che usa dei numeri
particolari bene questi numeri sono una
sequenza particolare passata alla storia
scoperta circa mille anni fa da un da un
pisano conosciuto scusate è un periodo
questo in cui i toscani sono un po in
auto e quindi è questo che vedete qua
che si stupisce di fronte al cavolo
perché questa è la famosa successione di
fibonacci questo ci dimostra non solo le
capacità algebriche del del cavolo che
non è che non è solo il cavolo vi sfido
a contare i petali di qualsiasi fiore e
troverete uno di questi numeri 4 è un
mistero che che vi sfido che vi dico di
cercare vedrete che funziona funziona
così quindi quello che possiamo fare è
quello di favorire il più possibile la
biodiversità cosa che purtroppo non
accade anzi facciamo esattamente il
contrario
defoe restiamo l'impossibile inquiniamo
atmosfere al mare e quant'altro
cementifichiamo quello che è possibile
cementificare ma anche oltre e
soprattutto coltiviamo quello che
possiamo coltivare essenzialmente con le
monocolture questo si traduce in un
impoverimento incredibile della della
biodiversità se prendiamo un altro
esempio un frutto che conosciamo
anch'esso perfettamente scopriamo una
cosa piuttosto inquietante nel 1920
potevamo acquistare comodamente fra 50
varietà di mele
ebbene dopo un
secolo circa se ci va bene possiamo
acquistare 10 possiamo scegliere fra 10
varietà di mele c'è di più del
superficie dedicata alla coltivazione
delle mele scopriamo che il 90 per cento
è dedicata a sole quattro varietà di
mela quindi quello che stiamo facendo è
perdere in maniera forse irreversibile
tutta la biodiversità che la natura ci
ha regalato fino adesso e serve magari
fare qualcosa d'importante
serve ognuno di noi fare qualcosa che
che possa invertire questa tendenza
noi nel nostro piccolo con la mia start
up grow the planet cerchiamo di fare
qualcosa non insegniamo solo ai nostri
utenti come coltivare il proprio orto
tramite un sistema una piattaforma che
affronta questa passione fantastica a
360 gradi ma cerchiamo di favorire anche
lo scambio dei semi ovvero all'interno
della nostra piattaforma gli utenti
usano sempre più i nostri mezzi per
scambiare sementi di piante rare e
sconosciute in via d'estinzione in modo
tale che si possa in questo modo
favorire la diffusione della
biodiversità perché noi avere the planet
pensiamo che biodiversità significhi
soprattutto opportunità chiudo con una
domanda preferito e scegliere la vostra
mela fra quattro varietà offre alle 7
mila t nella natura ci mette a
disposizione
grazie dell'attenzione